et monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur bernard perrut monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre dans toutes les
communes de france
les maires et les élus locaux sont
passés de l'inquiétude au désarroi
il se mobilise et vous interpelle mais
vous ne les écoutez pas la baisse
cumulée des dotations de l'état trop
forte et trop brutale près de 16
milliards d'euros d'ici 2017 et les
transferts de charges et d'obligations
tout cela est devenu insoutenable en
vous attaquant ainsi aux communes vous
attaquer à la vie quotidienne des
français
c'est en effet le recul ou la
suppression de services publics
indispensables à la population qui se
profile de la petite enfance aux
personnes âgées de l'école au sport à la
culture et à la vie associative
il faudra se serrer la ceinture c'est
aussi mettre en péril l'investissement
avec une peste 25 % des montants prévus
d'ici 2017
adieu les projets bâtiments travaux
prévus dans nos villes et villages pour
améliorer le cadre de vie et combien de
dizaines de milliers d'emplois seront
sacrifiés et d'entreprises en péril
ajoutant du chômage au chômage et cela
est très grave
et quelle situation catastrophique pour
plus de 1500 communes
ils seront bientôt dans le rouge et
passeront sous la tutelle de l'état
alors monsieur le premier ministre
quelles mesures prendre et vous
rapidement afin de maintenir la vie et
l'espoir dans deux communes à moins que
votre seul but soit de transférer sur
les élus locaux
l'échec de votre politique et de votre
impopularité
allez vous infléchir cette marche forcée
des vestes dotation écouter les maires
de france
soucieux de bonne gestion chaque jour au
service de leurs concitoyens ils
méritent votre soutien et si vous leur
accordé votre confiance je ne doute pas
que vous leur répondre et
personnellement dans quelques instants
la parole est à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député bernard perrut là encore essayons
de nous rassembler sur un stand idée
simple sur lesquels nous pourrions nous
mettre d'accord
d'abord une trajectoire a été votée par
le parlement parlement qui effectivement
incluent une baisse des dotations de
l'état en direction des collectivités
publiques chaudraies des collecteurs
local pardon je voudrais rappeler que
les recettes des collectivités
territoriales sont constitués pour un
quart environ par des transferts de
l'état il reste donc trois quarts de
recettes pour ces collectivités qui
connaissent une dynamique parfois
spontanée par leur croissance ou qui a
été décidé par le parlement puisque vous
avez revaloriser les bases des valeurs
locatives vous avez décidé en terre de 0
9%
la grosse part des dotations c'est la
dgf 7 dgf le récent rapport le travail
actuellement produit par cystine pires
bonne je veux remercier pour pour son
travail au début accompagné par le
regretté sénateur jean germain à poser
un constat c'est que la dgf aujourd'hui
est devenu par sédimentation de
différentes mesures complètement opaque
injuste et illisible
c'est ce chantier auquel le gouvernement
vous appelle chantier de réforme de la
djs dgf pardon pour plus de justice
une meilleure répartition parce que le
constat est accablant vous dites qu'il
n'ya pas d' écoute
j'étais aux côtés du premier ministre
croit il ya une semaine où le président
baroin est venu dialoguer le dialogue se
poursuit à selon deux pistes ont été
évoquées un renforcement de l'assiette
du fonds de compensation de la tva la
constitution d'une dotation
d'investissement et le chiffre d'un
milliard a été évoquée ce dialogue va
reprendre et nul doute que nous
arriverons a entraîné l'ensemble des
collectivités avec l'état dans une
baisse de la dépense publique
merde